Thỏ ăn tiền với tên, còn giống đốc gơ quan năng lượng quaint tự của tế nhà Rafeu Grosse, ngày 30 thần từ chờ biết,
chờ tiền đã đặt tiền bộ rất đáng kể trong truy trình hạm nhận.
Ông Grosse cũng cho biết, tôi có này kiện nhà dựa thang hoạt động tại khu vức khẩm dòng biên,
bao gồm lo và nữ 5 mề gà quá, có sự tại trế và lo và nữ nề.
Y ai của phát hiện giống hiệu xí dựng một cơ sở làm giấu ra nhiều mới,
có đằng nghiệm tương tự các nhà máy hiện có, phát chúng ta nghiên cứu chiến lượng của tế CIS ES,
thì ngành bệ tình gần đây cùng cố nhìn định rằng,
nâ hửa sản xuất và liệu hạm nhân của biển dẫn đăng được mừng dòng.
Ông Grosse ước tính chờ tiền hện sự dụng vài chục đo đạn hạm nhận.
Đồng thời nhận mạnh xù hướng ra tăng lượng sản xuất là đáng mọi ngày.
Tuy nhiên, ông cho biết chưa có bằng chứng chất thấy ngà hỗ trợ chự tiết chuy trình này.
Chúc khi đó, chờ tiền chưa ra phản huổi chính thức.
Dự quan xa chựa rằng biểu mở giống trình hạm nhận của thế làm ra tăng thang thang khu vực.
Chúc bởi kẻnh các nỗ lượng kiểm soát phổ biển bố kiêm nhận, bằng gặp nhìn tức.